ils sont tout simplement imparables
les états-unis ne veulent pas limiter
vos partenariats avec d'autres pays
nous voulons rendre vos partenariats avec
nous
encore plus forts
nous ne voulons pas vous faire choisir
nous voulons vous donner des choix
ensemble
nous pouvons livrer de vrais  avantages pour notre
peuple
sur les questions qui comptent le plus pour eux
les états-unis veulent renforcer
nos partenariats à travers l'afrique de manière à
servir vos intérêts
nos intérêts et les intérêts des
personnes dans le monde dont la vie et l'avenir
dépendent en partie
de ce que nous pouvons réaliser ensemble les
américains  et les Africains partagent un désir
de vivre dans des endroits où leurs droits sont
respectés
leurs voix sont entendues leurs gouvernements leur
répondent et leur offrent en
travaillant ensemble
nous pouvons soutenir la démocratie
dans nos pays
et dans le monde
[Applaudissements]